[Musik]
bismark erst ist broadbent munich re mit
dieser geschichte anfangen was wir
letzte woche schon gesehen haben nämlich
wie wahrnehmung bei als orte ließ
fusioniert und damit es nicht langweilig
wird habe ich das beispiel verändert
jetzt haben wir einen frosch und kein
baum und lustig prozesse zeichnen das
ist macht immer spaß und ich will sie
auch was erklären was ich letzte woche
erklären wollte aber tritt als die zeit
mir ein bisschen schonen und ihr habt es
noch nicht erklärt es gab ein problem in
der praktischen philosophie die
wahrnehmung und er in allgemeinen wie
begreifen funktioniert nämlich dass man
intuitiv behaupten könnte dass das
wahrgenommene und der wahrnehmen de oder
das wahrnehmen
irgendwas gemeinsam haben müssen
zum beispiel ist es naheliegend dass ein
körper von einem anderen körper
wahrgenommen werden muss oder vielleicht
könnte man denken wenn ich erde
begreifen will also wahrnehmen will muss
er der in meinem körper anwesend sein
dass das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
abstrakt aber denken sie daran wie
funktioniert mein tastsinn
also haben wir das solides haben wir was
solides sie können dann in verbindung
kommen meine hand und der tash weil sie
beide solide elemente beinhalten nämlich
erde also man könnte sagen
wenn wir also wenn ich einen dämon mit
nur aus feuer werde könnte ich ihn nicht
antasten weil ich keine erde in meinen
körper hätte vielleicht
und tatsächlich bei empedokles von
finden wir belege dafür dass er genau
diese theorie vertreten hat zum beispiel
behauptete er dass das dass der augapfel
aus allen vier elementen besteht
deswegen ist alles sichtbar
das hat er in einem gedicht geschrieben
er nennt die elemente oft nach den
göttern den heimischen garten und die
idee es dass alle vier götter in meinem
auge anwesens sind also es gibt feuer in
meinem auge und erde wasser luft und
deswegen kann ich alles wahrnehmen
wer das ist eine idee leider gibt es
auch die genau entgegengesetzte idee
auch bei den vorzug heute können nämlich
dass wenn ich wahrnehmung ist eine
veränderung die wir gesehen haben also
veränderung war das wirklich ist materie
und abwesende die abwesenheit einer form
und dann die gleiche materie anwesenheit
davon und das damit wird ja unter
anderem wahrnehmen
dann erklären wahrnehmen es auch eine
veränderung und im allgemeinen wenn wir
veränderungen haben brauchen wir immer
nichts zwei sachen die ähnlich sind
sondern zwei sachen die nicht ähnlich
sind zum beispiel um feuer zu löschen
auch etwas kaltes oder nach sechs oder
beides zum beispiel wasser was er es
nass und kalt wenn luft und wasser luft
feuer was heiß und trocken ist
nach der antiken elementen theorie
und das ist eine typische veränderung
und im allgemeinen wenn wir also wenn
wir denken ich bin genauso wie die welt
wie kann die welt nicht verändern
wenn ich zum beispiel trocken denn wie
kann die trockenheit der welt meinen
körper verändern wenn ich trocken so
sowohl trocken wie nach st dann würde
die welt mir nicht gar nichts verändern
können müssen es nichts der in sicht
nach dass sie das ich feucht oder
trocken denn weil trockenheit draußen
und drinnen werden sich gegenseitig
nicht beeinflussen
genau wie vorher feuer nicht löschen
kann einfluss feuer nicht vorher wird
von wasser beeinflusst also wir haben
diese zwei weg ins erste theorien und
beide sind eigentlich ziemlich intuitiv
oder naheliegend natürlich ist also die
art und weise wie ich das gerade
beschrieben habe diese in zwei
gegensätze lehren die wir bei den
vorsorgenden das ist nicht unbedingt die
theoretische lage wie sie bei den
vorschlag als ich ihn wirklich zu finden
war ist das ist aber ein raster was
alles benutzt um die theorien zu
beschreiben und zwar im ersten buch der
von der anima also sieht ja ein problem
nämlich dass wir zwei intuitive
vorschläge haben die was die
voraussetzungen für wahrnehmen
wahrnehmung sind nämlich unendlichkeit
oder eben ähnlichkeit und dann will er
susann anerkennen dass beide theorien
plausibel sind
und nicht nur die richtige antwort geben
sondern auch sogar erklären warum diese
zwei entgegengesetzte vorschläge
beides so brasilien sind das ist typisch
dass dort ließ was ja nicht immer aber
sehr oft macht ist
vorherige philosophen zu erwähnen weil
sie plausible an vielleicht nur
ansatzweise plausible für solche
theorien geliefert haben
trotzdem findet er diese vorherige
theorien bedürftig und versucht diese
theorien zu verbessern aber aber nicht
dadurch dass er einfach die alte theorie
wird wirft sozusagen sondern will er
erklären warum das so plausibel war oder
wie es ist dass diese kluge leute so
diese genau diese lösungen gekommen sind
obwohl sie nicht recht hatten hatten sie
sozusagen teil teilweise recht hier in
diesem fall ist sehr klar dass nicht das
allein nicht reicht haben können
es kann nicht sein dass wahrnehmung
durch ähnlichkeit erklärt wird und
unendlichkeit mindestens wenn es nichts
aus zwei perspektiven ist und das wird
natürlich die lösung sein
aber sie hatten beide irgendwas richtig
das ist die idee ok dann bei seiner
warnung le mans serie sehen wir genau
wie ihr dieses problem oder diese
antinori löst nämlich dass mein auge
einem grünen objekt zum beispiel einen
frosch schon in einer weise unähnlich
ist aber auch in einer weise ähnlich
mein auge ist unähnlich war es in der
ersten linie also von haus aus an sich
nicht grün erst der frosch aber schon
andererseits ist mein auge dem frosch
ähnlich weil mein auge grün werden kann
also und alles soll ich würde sagen dass
mein auge der potenzial i tät nach schon
grün ist und zwar die ganze zeit weil
flüssigkeit die flüssigkeit in meinem
einer kapsel durchsichtig ist kann alle
farben auf sich nehmen
hat also eine potenzial i tät grün zu
werden wir haben schon gesehen es gibt
eine frage ob das heißt wer wirklich
grün werden oder nur geiste grünen
werden was auch immer das heißen soll
aber wie auch immer das geschieht kann
mein auge grün werden ist aber nichts in
der also bevor ich sehe ist zum beispiel
wenn meine augen zu sehen ist hat meine
alle farben nur der potentially tät nach
sobald ich was sie zb einen frosch wird
diese farbe in mein auge aktualisiert
oder verwirklicht wird dann wirklich
grün genau wie der frosch ist also wir
haben im allgemeinen plätze tiefe
fähigkeiten in dem körper die formen von
der welt sich die sich von in der welt
aufnehmen können
irgendwie und das heißt nur dass die
potenziale täten haben die in die wirtin
die wirklichkeit eintreten können
sozusagen
und ist immer der fall
das dass das was der potenziale tag nach
assist von irgendwas beeinflusst wird
was schon der aktualität oder
wirklichkeit nach es ist zum beispiel
das was potentiell warm ist wird von
einem wirklichen hat einen wirklich
warmen ging oder eine eine sache die
wirklich warm ist beeinflusst nämlich
erwerbs ähnlicher weise wird das was der
potenzial i tät nach grün oder kalt oder
wie auch immer das was der potenzial i
tät nach eine eigenschaft besitzt wird
von irgendwas beeinflusst was diese
genau diese eigenschaft schon der
wirklichkeit nachbesetzt das benutzt er
auch zum beispiel tasten zu erkennen ich
kann härte oder wärme kälte und so
weiter mit meinem tasten spuren und das
ist weil mein fleisch genau in der mitte
ist also fleisch ist nach adam ries
genau also wenn man nicht krank ist ist
der körper und fahren ist mein fleisch
genau in der mitte zwischen warm und
kalt und ist deswegen genau richtig und
wärme und kälte zu begreifen glaube ich
habe keine mehr aber ich habe 150
mitgebracht und es kann nicht sein dass
alle gibt es übrigens anders
diese theorie ist übrigens also erstens
ein bisschen box denn sie alle gobox
diese dass sein merken was heißt sie
anders aus das auf deutsch
aber das ist dass es dieses märchen mit
den mädchen so was in ein haus ein
tretet und da da wohnen drei bären
sie findet 333
ein schlüssel es zu warm eines zu kalt
und das just wright mine fleiß ist just
wright 3 was nichts weder zu warm noch
zu kalt ist erst das zweite ist diese
theorie sehr einflussreich in der
späteren fürsten sogar in der medizin zb
sagt der spätantike 200 christus
mediziner gallen genau dasselbe über
fleisch fleisch isst hat hat perfektes
gleichgewicht zwischen allen
körperlichen eigenschaften ist nicht zu
nass nichts zutraut nicht so war nicht
so kalt und interessanterweise ist er
sagt auch dass die perfekte ernährung
für uns ist das was am meisten am
leichtesten ins fleisch verwandelt
werden kann
und das heißt dass wir ernährung wenn
wir gesund bleiben wollen sollten wir in
erding aussuchen was genau diese dieser
natur ist also nicht zu warm nicht zu
kalt nicht sozusagen nichts zu folgt das
heißt wir sollten eigentlich irgendwas
essen was genau oder mindestens genauso
nah dran sollten möglichst ähnlich ist
zu menschlichem fleisch natürlich heißt
es nicht dass wir andere menschen essen
sollten also die die beste ernährung
nach gallien ist schweinefleisch weil
ich weine von körper nach die englischen
fans zu
menschen also vegetarier pech gehabt
so also wie man hier sehen sie dass es
dass es also zum teil vielleicht ein
bisschen und überzeugend ist aber schon
eine interessant ein einziges anderes
beispiel wo er diese grundprinzipien
seiner naturphilosophie einsatzpotenzial
i tät wirklichkeit veränderung und so
weiter und so fort
spannende weise benutzt er die genau
diese konstellation von ideen umdenken
zu erkennen und das ist der das heutige
thema heute haben wollte ich intellekt
oder geist bei hdj ließ erklären man
hier auch will alles argumentieren dass
der geist allen objekten allen möglichen
begreifbaren objekten der potenzial i
tät nach schon englisch ist also das
heißt ich bin der potenzial i tät nach
der form nach mit frosch identisch ist
identisch beweis dafür
ich kann zuerst frosch denken und dann
frosch nicht denken
also wenn ich forsche begreife dann
haben wir eine verwandlung in meinem
geist wo die form der des frosches
zuerst abwesend ist aber nicht völlig
abwesend sondern prozent sieht nur
potenziell anwesend der wirklichkeit
aber nach abwesend und dann wenn ich ein
frosch denke da wird mein geist
verwirklicht sozusagen und begreift
frosch das heißt hat die form des
forschers der wirklichkeit nach nochmal
heran
von dem was wir letzte woche gesehen
haben
wir hatten diese unterscheidung zwischen
erste potenzial i tät zweite potenzial i
tät was gleich ist die erste möglichkeit
ins zweite wirklichkeit also was er
sagen will ist dass der genau wie mein
auge
zuerst potenziell grün ist also hat die
aktive fähigkeit wirklich größer werden
und dann sieht das zweite wirklichkeit
genauso ist mein geist nicht nur ein
leeres unding
also es nicht ist nicht nichts sondern
ist die fähigkeit irgendwas aktiv zu
begreifen und das hier sehen wir nicht
so es so wichtig ist zwischen erster und
zweiter potenzial i tät zu unterscheiden
geist ist nicht erste potenzial i tät
genau wie sich die sicht also sehr
verwirrten genau wie sehvermögen ist
geist eine zweite potenzial i tät oder
erste wirklichkeit die ganze seele ist
eine erste wirklichkeit seele drängte
mit sich oder ist nur fähigkeiten aktiv
also wirklich fähigkeiten nur nur eine
fähigkeit ist nur die fähigkeit oder die
möglichkeit irgendwas zu tun
von daher eine art potenzial i tät aber
mehr als bloße potenzial i tät
ist es schon eine fähigkeit die man
erworben hat dadurch dass man bisher ist
sobald man geboren wird hat man manche
seelische fähigkeiten von haus aus zu
sagen kostenlos
zum beispiel dass man atmen kann sich
ernähren kann sehen kann und zum
beispiel es gibt aber auch andere
fähigkeiten die man noch nicht einfach
als mensch hat zum beispiel deutsch
knacken
also wenn ein baby die bäume werden kann
das baby normalerweise noch nicht
deutsch sprechen
in meiner erfahrung es gibt eine
geschichte über die über den buddha dass
er sofort als er geboren ist ist er
aufgestanden ist durch das zimmer
gegangen und hat irgendwas über das
leiden der menschen gesagt aber dass auf
diese art und selbst das nicht auf
deutsch natürlich sondern auf bali
wahrscheinlich also selbst der bruder
konnte kein deutsch als er geboren ist
also deutsch sprechen ist es für uns
alle als menschen zuerst nur eine
fähigkeit der pott ersten prozent
sanität nach kommt aber mit erwerb der
deutschen der deutschen sprachkenntnisse
als zweite prozent und wenn man deutsch
wirklich nutzt um zu verstehen oder zu
sprechen wie wir es alle machen haben
wir als zweite möglichkeit
eine geschichte dass die leute nämlich
den lebensabend ihren wollten
okay das ist nichts das ist nun anders
würde ich sagen dass es was sinnvoll
sie haben nur dass das passiert wenn man
erste potenzial und zweite potenzielle
täter verwechselt
das ist genau das problem ja interessant
ich dachte sie würden sagen es gibt eine
geschichte dass leute englische babys
adoptiert haben um siehst du davon zu
retten dass sie englisch sprechen
[Musik]
also geist ist auch so groß wie gesagt
auch eine erste wirklichkeit oder
zweiter potenzial i tät ist die
fähigkeit ideen zu begreifen und hier
die passage die ich auf deutsch vorlesen
wollte aber ich lese das auf englisch
vor
da werden sie die gelegenheit haben zu
hören wie gut ich englisch sprechen kann
das sogar besser als mein deutsch peking
haariges depressiv
[Musik]
also genau das auge ist ähnlich zu dem
objekt das wahrgenommen wird nichts weil
das auge schon im voraus genau die
gleiche form hat wenn ich schon im
voraus die grüne form hätte würde das
auge schon grün sehen würde alles grün
seien immer willkommen später zu diesem
punkt zurück also ist nur potenziell
identisch der form nach und genauso ist
alles gedacht schon im geist potenzial
vorhanden
das ist die eigentliche idee und
jetzt können sie vielleicht können sie
sich herz können sie vielleicht erwidern
okay gut aber jetzt habe ich 20 minuten
gebraucht nur um es zu sagen dass wir
denken können
da bei alles was ich gesagt habe ist das
was zu sagen draußen ist also was was
sind praktika sind in der wirklichkeit
nach aktuell draußen existiert kann auch
in meinem geist vorkommen aber das heißt
anscheinend nur dass ich darüber denken
kann aber das wissen wir schon
allerdings fahrt nun zum glück gibt es
mehr zu sagen also die verletzung ist
noch nicht vorbei aber ich selbst selbst
selbst jetzt wo wir relativ wenig gesagt
haben gibt es mindestens vielleicht eine
also vielleicht ein beleg was in die
richtung gehen könnte eine frage vom
letzten mal zu beantworten
sie werden sich daran und ich habe das
aber schon erwähnt heute dass es einen
streit bei aristoteles interpreten gibt
ob die flüssigkeit in meinem auge
wirklich dröhnen wird also sichtbar
selbst dran sich selbst sichtbar grün
wird oder nur die form der grünen farbe
geistig annimmt und das ist mir städten
aber was wir sicher wissen ist dass mein
geist kein frosch wird also selbst wenn
alles sollte die ist ziemlich
physikalisch denkt oder
funktionalistische man sagt bei
wahrnehmung ist es wird es sicherlich
klar dass geistige formen in meinem in
meiner seele erscheinen ohne körperliche
veränderung also da das ist eine koppel
vielleicht eine ganz körperliche
veränderung grün werden in dem auge
vielleicht nichts vielleicht dass das
nicht buchstäblich grün werden das sind
unklar
aber hier bei dem geist geist ist immer
der wie sie sehen werden ich habe nicht
wirklich so aus stade
jetzt haben das wäre wirklich sehr
passend gewesen aber ein geist seele
geist dieselben werden ist wirklich und
körperlich hat keinen kein körperliches
orden und von daher können wir sicher
sein dass die seele oder der geist wenn
er die form eines dinges annimmt oder
empfängt dass es keine körperliche
veränderung so was können wir sagen
um diese etwas skizzenhafte beschreibung
ein bisschen auszufüllen leider liefert
über die seele hier nicht so viele
informationen wie wir vielleicht die wir
uns vielleicht eher wünschen würden also
diese erklärung potenzial i tät
wirklichkeit
das ist die haupt theoretische
beschreibung des denkens in der arena
oder er über die szene aber das ist
eigentlich das hat eigentlich gute
gründe weil die über über die säle kein
werk technologie ist dass sein werk über
psychologie das was anderes wir haben
gesehen er will alles erkennen von
ernährung und fortpflanzung bis zu
denken und was er sagen will ist dass
das er nach einem einheitlichen muster
all diese fähigkeiten erklären kann und
es interessiert ihn zum beispiel wie
diese elemente im körper verwandt ist
aber eine lange erklärung was wissen er
überhaupt ist oder was verständnis ist
wohl denn das besteht das werde ich hier
fehl am platz das ist nicht sein thema
und deswegen könnte man vielleicht sagen
dass ein ähnlich wie
bei platon die dialogen wo er sei es
allen theorie darstellt sind nicht
unbedingt die dialogen wo er seine
technologie darstellt also die die haupt
der haupt dialog fürs allen harry bähre
phaidon habt dialog für technologie
werden - und wir haben gesehen es gab
eine beziehung zwischen diesen zwei
texten aber die themen waren wirklich
anders psychologie gibt es auf teile der
politik wie wir gesehen haben oder auch
sehr interessanter dialog den wir nicht
gelesen haben oder nicht besprochen
haben ein punkt ist man man muss nicht
unbedingt erwarten
das denken aus düsseldorf logische
fähigkeit gleichseitigen mit ms melody
besprochen wird und das wird irgendwann
hier tatsächlich ist das nicht der fall
wo bespricht er technologie gibt es ein
werk oder als not least das multi
überhaupt eigentlich schon würden
vielleicht sagen nichts aber ich würde
behaupten dass der beste text einer
technologie nicht über die seele ist
sondern ein anderes werk namens
analytiker post der ior also zweiter
analytik sie ohne sehr viel über alles
zu wissen werden sie vielleicht schon
geahnt haben das ist auch eine erste
analytik politiker priora und das ist
denn da in der tat der fall
es gibt diese zwei bücher die analytik
und heutige priora erst analytik ist
sein werk über logik oder logistik da
beschreibt er wie schlüssige argumente
gebaut werden was der unterschied ist
zwischen schlüssige und unschlüssige
argumente wie welche rolle modalität
also notwendigkeit und möglichkeit da in
der logik spielen können und so weiter
und so fort das ist wirklich schon vor
zwei wochen gesagt dass es logik
erfunden hat der text wo der logik
erfindet ist erster analytik dann kommt
zweiter an nötig für die antike
tradition der auslebung situation war
analytik die post ihre pause oder
einfach ein weiteres werk in der logik
und zwar der gipfel der logik also die
ihre idee war es gibt mehrere werke so
logik und die zwei hauptwerke sind die
zwei analytik erste analytik bescheid
argumente im allgemeinen zweite analytik
beschreibt die beste art von argument
definitionen und das ist irgendwie
richtig also dieses werk ist offenbar
sehr eng mit seinen archäologischen
theorie verbunden
allerdings kann man auch sagen dass
dieses werk in einer gewissen weise
seine wissenschaftstheorie oder
kosmologie dann darstellt genau weil
hier in der zweiten analytik erklären
will was es erst beweise zu haben
es ist nicht das einzige thema des
werkes aber das ist dass das ist das
hauptthema
was es ist irgendwas bewiesen zu haben
und ihn unter welchen bedingungen ein
beweissicherheit und sicheres
verständnis mit sich bringt also die ist
eine idee ist im allgemeinen wenn wir
ein argument haben mit presse und ein
schluss wir interessieren uns hier in
der zweiten analytik dafür unter
gleichen bedingungen zählt unser schluss
als wissen hat das thema
wovon wir natürlich das wort app ismo
logi haben also er will unterscheiden
zwischen argumenten die härteste liefern
das sind die beweise und die die keine
sicher ist kein sicheres wissen dann
etablieren
und da die werden vielleicht auch
schlüssige argumente aber keine
argumente die app ist denn dann
begründen können
und also die idee des beweises ist ja so
als seien zwar dass man später sind es
21 sieht das der titel dieses werkes
mache ich mal einfach beweis es zum
beispiel auf arabisch heißt dieses werk
portalen beweis nichts weiter nötig also
dass wir das zweite analytik nennen ist
aber gut belegt ist sagt auch der
schotte ließ und sagen die lateiner des
rollers ticker also auf jeden fall die
frage ist dann und wann wir wissen
besitzen war nichts antwort wir haben
wissen wenn wir es so ein argument haben
was wirklich aus beweis zählt und dann
gibt er uns eine reihe von bedingungen
die erfüllt werden müssen und hier
werden wir detaillierter sehen was das
ich schon vor zwei wochen gesehen gesagt
habe als ich all das ließ zuerst
vorgestellt habe nämlich dass seine
maßstäbe oder erwartungen für wissen
sehr sehr hoch gestellt sind genau wie
bei platon natürlich nicht weil er
annehmen will dass wir irgendwelche
geistige nicht in welche ideen haben
also er hat keine ideen lehre oder
formulare und ideen von blatt und sogar
ab die schon gesagt habe trotzdem
erwartet er von wissen oder von herpes
thema das wir wirklich einen sehr hohen
grad von sicherheit nun allgemeinheit
haben wie sie erzählen werden
ok so im allgemeinen wie schaut ein
bereit sein beweis aus ich weiß
natürlich ein bisschen vereinfachen
aber sie werden schon die idee verstehen
im allgemeinen ist für des ortes ein
solo gis muss also in zynismus eine
argument mit zwei prämisse und dann
entschluss so also bqs und was er in der
ersten analytik schon gemacht hat war so
erklären welche prämisse welche
schlüssel dann begründen können
seine logik sagt man oft ist mit
prädikat eve also das griechische werke
ist kategorien
und davon haben wir die den titel
kategorien die prämisse haben immer zwei
themen die in verbindung gebracht werden
zum beispiel on y ist und deswegen extra
zum beispiel frost ist ihr das hier ist
lebend deswegen frosch ist lebend tipp
das ist ein typischer typisches argument
es muss aber nicht so allgemein seien es
zum beispiel das konnte es ein frosch
ist ihr heinrich ist frosch ein
heimliches der name des frosches das ist
das ist zufällig ist das heimlich
frosch ist ihr heinrich ist frosch
deswegen heinrich ist hier ist auch
schlüssig
dann haben wir zum beispiel negationen
zum beispiel könnte man sich fragen wenn
man schreiben würde ex ist absolut ist
nicht ex kann man daraus ziehen cs nicht
ex und so weiter und so fort sie können
selber entscheiden ob das christlich ist
oder nicht spielt mit somit negationen
um anerkennt dass man manchmal über
einzelne sachen produziert zum beispiel
heinrich der frosch manchmal über
allgemeine begriffe oder grüne versalien
haben die gesagt sagt ja manchmal gibt
es eine ganze einen ganzen teil der
ersten analytik wo er diese modelle
wörter dann bespricht zum beispiel wenn
man sagt notwendig xy möglicherweise y
ist so könnte man den schluss ziehen
notwendig ist oder nur möglicherweise ex
sz und so weiter aber dass das also so
detailliert wir sind wir das nicht
besprechen
aber nachdem er das alles in der ersten
blutig beschrieben hat ist er jetzt in
der lage zu sagen was ein beweis ist ein
beweis hat auch sowas hat aber andere
bedingungen erstens muss es der fall
sein dass diese prämisse für uns besser
bekannt sind
als der schluss weil wir wollen
irgendetwas zeigen oder beweisen
und wenn wir wenn wir irgendwie den
schluss besser schon begreifen als die
prämisse ist immer viel wissen sicher
dass der schluss war ist aber ob die
prämisse war es sind oder nicht sind wir
nicht so sicher
dann liefert das natürlich kein neues
verständnis anhalten wenn wenn diese
prämisse wirklich unbekannt sind oder
ihm ein unbekannter im sinne von uns
sicher oder fraglich können wir sie
natürlich nichts sicher und natürlich
nicht sicherstellen dass der schluss war
es an hallen mit diesen prämissen also
erstens das und das ist ziemlich
offensichtlich würde ich sagen also für
ihn müssen beweise um apps games zu
schaffen erschaffen also um verständnis
zu bringen müssen sie wirklich was
erklären oder also verständigen lassen
und diese bedingung hat auch mit dem mit
der nächsten beweise zu tun
diese verbindung zwischen den zwei
prämisse pressen das heißt die mitte der
mittlere teil
das muss nicht nur der fall sein sondern
auch die erklärung dafür sein dass der
schluss war ist
zum beispiel ist nehmen wir an dass so
dass frösche dass alle frösche in
australien sind weil existieren nur in
australien
dann können wir sagen heinrich ist ein
frosch frösche ist in australien
deswegen ist heimlich in australien
aber das ist kein beweis weil die
tatsache dass heimlich in australien ist
ist nur zufällig der fall und das kann
ich sie jetzt kann ich sogar beweisen
ich könnte heimlich von australien nach
europa bringen und eigentlich wäre immer
noch ein frosch also diese diese dieser
bindeglied zwischen der xy mussten nicht
nur stimmig sein muss die ursache sein
damit sehen wir dass für softies beweise
also im schlechten sinne immer nicht nur
verständnis bringen sondern eine
erklärung bringen
und jetzt könnten sie vielleicht zurück
zur physik denken und sehen es gibt vier
arten von ursachen materie form werk
ursache zwerg ursache und die können all
diese rolle spielen ok also zum beispiel
hammer ist aus eisen es hat deswegen ist
hammerhart und dass es die das ist
wirklich die erklärung warum hammerhart
erst da also die der grund wohl für
immer hart sind ist das ein hammer aus
eisen es und reisen ist hat das ist eine
immaterielle ursache oder erklärung oder
hummer es ist um nagel
so was macht man also zu hermann aber um
loszuschlagen
alles was nagel schlägt ist hart
deswegen ist hammerhart
das ist genau der selbe schluss aber mit
einer anderen erklärung nämlich zweck
ursache dass der zweck eines hammers
russischen zu schlagen und das ist eine
ein anderer gründe zusammen warum
hammerhart ist man muss nichts zwischen
den zwei erklärungen wählen natürlich
die sind beide richtig aber das heißt
nur dass wir manchmal irgendwas aus mehr
als einer perspektive verstehen können
wir können verstehen warum hammerhart
ist wegen der materie ursache oder wegen
der zweite sache in diesem beispiel
ok also das ist das ist ein 2 die zweite
bedingung erste bedingung war die
prämisse müssen besser begriffen also
die wir müssen diese besser im griff
haben als der schluss damit unser wissen
wirklich erweitert wird zweitens müssen
wir hier eine erklärung haben
drittens nicht sehr überraschende weise
müssen die prämisse war sein weil die
kann es nicht beweisen ohne ware
prämisse die sie wahrscheinlich schon in
der im der logik logik vorlesung gelernt
haben gibt es schlüssige das schlüssige
argumente oder vergessen was ich sagen
würde es gibt schlüssige argumente wo
die prämisse falsch sind ja zum beispiel
deutschland ist eine mannschaft die das
erste gruppenspiel gewonnen hat
mannschaften die das erste gruppenspiel
gewonnen hat haben gute chancen zur
zweiten runde zu kommen
deswegen hat deutschland gute gründe
gute chancen zum zweiten und dessen
kommen das ist interessant weil der
schluss wahrscheinlich aus dem bast
deutschland hat eigentlich immer noch
relativ gute chancen in die zweite runde
zu kommen
also ich habe hier eine eine wahrheits
mit einer falschen prämisse bewiesen
also da also das argument war schlüssig
also das heißt der form nach war das
argument tadellos und der schluss war
sogar war angenommen dass das wahr ist
aber diese vermisse war offenbar falsch
so was geht nicht wenn wir irgendetwas
beweisen weiter wenn wir wissen
profitieren wollen dürfen wir nicht
einfach falsche prämisse teilnehmen das
ist auch natürlich nicht sehr
überraschend
aber sie sehen wie wichtig ist für hatte
sotschis ist dass diese dass diese
prämisse wirklich so sagen so der welt
korrespondieren und dass sie wirklich
wissen produzieren also wir müssen mehr
lernen daraus und wir dürfen keine
fehler machen also ist es geht es heißt
es geht nicht wenn wir hier am ende
irgendwas war das glauben aber wegen
falschen prämissen wurde auch wegen
kristen die nur zufällig der fall sind
zb mein beispiel mit der mit dem frosch
aus australien
vielleicht eine anderes beispiel bleibt
es mit dem forscher sein weil ein
bisschen verwirrend
nehmen wir an dass das eisen was ich zur
verfügung habe
ist rot dann könnten wir sagen habe es
aus eisen eisen ist rot deswegen ist
hammer rot und das wäre es dort war
schlüssel
also das sind keine logische fehler
eingetreten
die prämisse ist ein war der schluss ist
war alles gut ist aber keine gute
erklärung weil die tatsache dass eisen
rot ist nur zufällig der fall ist
ok also das ist das wäre für ihn keine
gute und gute erklärung der härte eines
hammers nicht einmal hätte meines vaters
bei der die tatsache dass mein hammer
protest ist wirklich nur zufall
das bringt mich zu einer weiteren
bedingungen diese prämisse sie müssen
nicht nur wasser sein und eine ursache
dann aussuchen
sie müssen auch essenziell
war es seien also die die beziehungen
hier diese traditionen wie er sagen
würde die beziehungen zwischen prädikat
und objekt in jeder prämisse und einem
schluss muss eine essentielle beziehung
sein und das haben wir schon gesehen
sie hätten sich an meinem beispiel mit
mensch und das mensch zum beispiel
lebend ist oder wahrzunehmen ist
essenziell für den mensch aber dass ein
mensch zum beispiel 70 kilo wiegt könnte
wahr sein da ich will persönliche das
web vielleicht mehr als sie erfahren
wollten über mich aber ich würde
ungefähr ungefähr 70
ich wäge 70 kilo ungefähr und also wie
groß ich bin werde ich nicht erwähnen
aber nicht sehr groß also ich will geht
70 kilo dass das ist wahr und ich könnte
ein argument zum beispiel mache also
peterwitz 70 kilo
alles was 70 kilo wiegt ist fähig ein
blatt papier zu halten damit das papier
nicht weg gewählt wird natürlich ist das
war peters deswegen fähig oder schwer
genug papier dann am boden fest zu
machen wäre das ist alles wahr ist hat
aber nichts mit wissenschaft zu tun
wissenschaft verständnis der welt muss
immer mit essentiellen prädikaten zu tun
haben und hier haben wir vielleicht die
fassung von dem was für bei platon
gesehen haben mit dem staat und die
weglaufen sich er sagte war der meinung
ist gut obwohl ich das problem ist dass
das sehr empfindlich ist
oder setzt du sonst ja schrecklich ist
oder nicht zuverlässig es ist vielleicht
dass er war der meinung ist nicht
zuverlässig ist die kanten werk laufen
was das heißt es dass das zuerst war es
und dann nichts und das problem mit ax
ident alle eigenschaften ist dass sie
eben nicht immer der fall sind die sind
die treten nicht immer oder es die das
stimmt nicht immer zu zum beispiel dass
ich 70 kilo wiege ich könnte ein kilo
abnehmen das wäre schön
also ich nehme ein kilo ab ich könnte
aber trotzdem papier am boden halten
wenn ich aufstehe und wenn ich sage
mensch ist setzt die kilo
alles was daraus folgt dass die wahre
meinung bei platon ist vielleicht im
moment oder gerade jetzt so verlasse
habe im allgemeinen nichts deswegen ist
das kein wissen keine wissenschaft oder
kein wissen sogar
kein system wir sehen dass das die
bedingungen kaufen jetzt an aber es
kommt schlimmeres damit das wirklich
sicher ist
und das hängt ja ein nasen zu hängen
zusammen mit dem was ich gerade gesagt
habe
damit es wirklich sicher ist und
essentiell ist muss es auch universal zu
treffen
also das heißt das flotte ließ beweise
die wissenschaft produzieren immer
allgemeine der universelle eigenschaften
der welt identifizieren und sind nie mit
die haben nie mit einzel sachen zu tun
also das heißt dass in unseren
salafismus werden xy uns alle keine
einzelne sachen sein sondern universal
ian das heißt nur allgemeine begriffe
zum beispiel dass das beispiel was wir
vorhatten frost ist ihr heimlich ist
frosch sie wissen dass ich mache ist das
passt nicht zum master aber stellen sie
sich vor
frosch ist hier heinrich ist frosch sie
können schon daraus den schluss ziehen
heinrich ist ihr das stimmt alles ist
aber keine wissenschaft es gibt keine
wissenschaft von heinrich es gibt kein
heinrich ökologie keine eine theologie
weil heinrich nur ein einzel ding ist
und sie können es sofort sehen warum
gehe ich ein problem hätten
nehmen wir an du bist ein du bist ein
heimlich golog halte sehr gut du hast
eine wissenschaft und dann stirbt
heinrich
das thema der wissenschaft weg das kann
übrigens wirklich passieren
in den sex tiger das ist eine traurige
geschichte aber es gab anthropologen die
sich ja für eine eine ein volk in der
platinen pazifik spezialisiert haben
nichts nicht viel der einzel verloren
aber es gab ein paar und das volk würde
vernichtet in einem krieg also alle
umgebracht und diese antwort das ist
nicht lustig aber die die folge war
irgendwie lustig diese anthropologen
sind alle historiker geworden weil also
das objekt der wissenschaft würde
gelöscht sein und ähnlicher fund ist sie
können sehen dass alles lesen das
natürlich gar nichts haben will dass die
plattform das wäre ein beispiel wie eine
überzeugung sogar eine sehr feste
überzeugung werk laufen könnte wenn man
einzelne dinge erforscht macht man keine
wissenschaft es sei denn wir benutzen
einzelne dinge um allgemeines
verständnis zu erreichen
natürlich wenn man frische wäsche kann
man schon erforschen natürlich also
frosch ist eine allgemeine eigenschaft
oder natur und um diese allgemeine
universellen natur zu erforschen nicht
erforschen zur erforschung muss man
einzelne moschee anschauen natürlich so
kommt man zu allgemeines verständnis
aber das verständnis als allgemein ok
und letzte bedingung
alle wahrheiten die hier einsetzen weil
sie essenziell universell und so weiter
sind die sind ewig der fall also all
diese wahrheiten sind nicht nur jetzt
war und auch nichts bis dato war die
sind häufig der fall
sie sind nicht empfindlich sind der
veränderung gegenüber nicht empfindlich
sie können nicht falsch werden oder
andere anders ausgesprochen könnte man
sagen dass diese prämisse und deswegen
der schluss notwendig sind das ist
vielleicht ein grund warum er in der
ersten analytics so viel über
notwendigkeit und möglichkeit gesagt hat
er hatte schon vor dass hier zu sagen
dass beweise notwendigkeiten erforschen
oder notwendige prämisse haben und
deswegen notwendigen schlüsse vielleicht
haben sie es schon gesehen dass es ein
problem hier gibt's nämlich dass frösche
es war ziemlich häufig vorkommen sind
aber eigentlich genau so empfindlich wie
ein volk im pazifischen ozean
also wenn alle frösche aussterben würden
nun auch die frosch wissenschaftler
historiker werden
die werden so logische historiker werden
oder palio biologen oder wie auch immer
die heißen oder dinosaurier also
dinosaurier forscher sind genau wie
diese an theologen und freut sich
natürlich von haus aus wussten dass sie
irgendwas erforschen was nicht mehr
existiert
zloty ist hat dieses problem nicht weil
er der überzeugung ist dass alle spezies
pcs plans pcs usw
ewig sind also für ihn sind die tiere
hatten die es jetzt gibt sind die
tierarten die seit ewigkeit existiert
haben und sind können sich nicht
verändern
es gab immer frösche ist wieder der
vorschläge und zwar genau die frösche
die es jetzt gibt es gibt keine theorie
der evolution bayer des ortes kann es
auch nicht geben
und wenn man ihm sagen würde dass
tierarten zuerst nichts existiert haben
dann entstanden sind
damit müsste entweder seine technologie
aufgeben oder er müsste sagen okay dann
gibt es keine wahre wissenschaft der
psychologie weil meine theorie nach
werden alle prämisse nicht ewig und
sicher nicht wahr nicht universal war
also das ist keine wissenschaft
in der im mittelalter haben die schola
sticker dieses problem gemerkt und also
erstens für sie war die welt mit ethik
sondern erschaffen
und auch die die sorge könnten es könnte
doch sein dass gott sich in einer ewigen
welt liegt das eigentlich bei gott ob
frösche existieren oder nicht
dann war er könnte porsche schaffen oder
nicht und vielleicht gibt es andere
tierarten die er nicht geschaffen hat
und so weiter
also was sie dann sind was sie sagen ist
sehr schlau
sie schlagen vor vielleicht ist das
alles irgendwie hypothetisch und das
heißt so was also wenn man sagt frosch
ist hier das city center also wenn man
das drängen ausdrückt sollte man sagen
wenn irgendwas ein frosch ist dann ist
das ding ein tier und das ist natürlich
ewig der fall weil es auch zu treffen
ist auch wenn es keine flasche
existieren weil wir können sagen okay im
moment gibt es keine frösche aber oder
gott hat keine frische geschaffen
gemacht aber falls er das machen würde
wenn er flasche machen würde würden die
frösche tier tiere seien okay das ist
aber nicht was alles haben will hat es
wirklich will wirklich dass es
irgendwelche sachen in der welt gibt die
diese sätze wahr machen und diese sätze
müssen essential essentielle bedingungen
ausdrücken sie müssen notwendig und
universal zu treffen seien
dann haben wir wissenschaft okay
deswegen würde es schon vorgeschlagen
das erste mal bei als lottes eigentlich
nicht wissen heißt sondern so was wie so
etwas wie verständnis es ist allgemeines
verständnis der welt das ist was er hat
ja also das geht natürlich wenn man das
gegenteil beweisen kann ist das falsch
daher habe er würde sagen wenn also die
ganze idee ist wenn wir keine ewige
wahrheiten entdecken haben wir bisher
kein wissen also wenn sie sagen würden
vielleicht gibt es nichts was ewig der
fall ist würde würde er sagen okay sind
skeptiker
sie glauben nicht an die möglichkeit des
wissens und das ist was ich immer wieder
sage die erwartungen die er von wissen
hat sind super hoch also wollte was er
haben will ist alles oder nichts
sie können vielleicht die sorge haben
wie können wir das überhaupt anwenden
ja man dass das ist alles so abstrakt
und universell wie können wir das wie
können wir das auf eine sache überhaupt
anwenden antwort kein problem natürlich
also wenn heinrich ein frosch ist und
wenn wir bewiesen haben dass zb flasche
wahrnehmen wesen sind weil frosch ist
ihr tier ist wahrnehmen
deswegen des frosch wahrnehmen was wir
verstehen also daten das wovon wird
wissen besitzen erst frosch ist
wahrnehmen
okay hier ist ein frosch einig hier ist
ein frosch einig jetzt habe ich so sagen
kompass oder als nebeneffekt dieses
beweises habe ich natürlich auch
bewiesen dass heinrich wahrnehmen das
weil er frosch ist aber das ist nicht
streng genommen
das ist nicht was ich weiß was ich weiß
ist frösche sind zunehmend und dann kann
ich das an einzelnen sachen anwenden
das ist der punkt man könnte sogar sagen
wir fangen mit eisen sachen an um
wissenschaft zu erwerben und dann wenn
wir wissenschaft an die einzel sachen
nachdem wir das begriffen haben und das
ist übrigens relevanz zu einem lassen
problem und bald komme ich zurück über
die seele
sie können sehen und vielleicht haben
sie dieses problem schon erkannt mal
hier von ihnen
sie können sehen dass ich den schluss
verstehe oder wissen über dieses diesen
schluss habe nur wenn ich diese prämisse
schon irgendwie in der tasche haben habe
ja also das ist sozusagen nur so stark
wie die prämisse er hat sogar gesagt ich
muss die prämisse besser verstehen heißt
entschluss also irgendwie habe ich die
schon ich habe die prämisse schon
ich muss ihn nur kombinieren den regeln
nach denen der erstmalig vorgestellt hat
okay das gut aber jetzt könnten sie
erwidern
okay vergessen wir diesen schluss wie
ist es dass ich wissen über diese
prämisse habe das also nur wenn das der
schluss eines anderen argument assist
zum beispiel
[Musik]
also und alt die bedingungen müssen noch
mal erfüllt werden muss eine ursache
seien die jetzt nutzen verbindet die
prämisse müssen war sicher
wenn das alles erfüllt ist dann hab ich
meine prämisse ja und hier auch also das
heißt für jede prämisse die hernehme
gibt es ein weiteres argument was die
prämisse dann begründet ok aber was ist
mit dieser prämisse ok xisco usa
deswegen ist okay gut aber was ist mit
der ersten premiere dieses argument ist
und so weiter
das seien regresses also das problem ist
wenn wir versuchen jede prämisse durch
ein beweis zu begründen werden wir bis
ins unendliche gehen und immer die
prämisse begründen müssen und es gab
auch antike skeptiker wie sie die mit
dass sie ein tick sind aber skeptisch
es gab in der antike skeptiker die genau
das gesagt haben sie haben gesagt okay
alles was sie beweisen wollen lieber als
oder liebevolles dogmatisch würde so
offen wird zu einem regresses führen
weil sie immer eine weitere begründung
von müssen werden deswegen sagt nein es
gibt manche prämisse die heiß sind
daher ist ein erstes prinzip also es
gibt erste prinzipien und das erklärte
im letzten kapitel von der zweiten
analytik die die acai diese erste
prinzipien können wir einfach
unmittelbar begleiten und die sind hab
diesen so sicher wie es geht und es sind
ein fundament für alles was folgt also
das heißt wenn man fragt wie es zum
beispiel nehmen höher an dass es ein
erstes prinzip wenn man nach einer
begründung dafür fragt machen wie geht
man ein fehler
es gibt keine weitere begründung für
dieses für diese prämisse
das ist ein erstes prinzip das begreifen
wir einfach so das sind sicherheiten
offensichtlich keiten zum beispiel
regeln der logik könnten beispiele seien
zb es kann nicht gleichzeitig y/y sein
oder könnten auch definitionen seien zum
beispiel das mensch tier ist ist nicht
unbedingt irgendwas was man beweisen
muss oder begründen muss das gehört
einfach zur natur des menschen dass
mensch tier ist
und interessanterweise hier haben wir
wirklich eine und ein und eine
unterscheidung zwischen ihm und platin
wenn er dann erklärt woher wir diese
prinzipien dann erwerben sagt er
durch wahrnehmung wir erforschen die
welt also helfen wird zurück sie dieses
wiesenfeld wir forschen die welt und die
sinnesorgane werden für aktualisiert
dann anhand dieser verwirklichung wird
der geist aktualisiert empfängt formen
und das beeinflussten sign teil was
damit kommt sind diese erste prinzipien
und wir begreifen ohne weitere
begründung
manche wahrheiten worauf wir die
restliche wissenschaft bauen können die
bausteine oder sie
ein haar fundament für ein gebäude
manchmal spricht man in der technologie
von foundations ja also von
nationalismus oder sowas
also dass alle also die das ganze wissen
passiert sich auf grundprinzipien und
die grundprinzipien haben keine weitere
rechtfertigung
dies sind einfach boden und die buckel
und diese boden prinzipien vorsorglich
ist sind diese prämisse die erste plätze
findet jetzt zurück über die zelle oder
hat jemand fragen dazu das war die
algerische technologie
das habe ich nicht gehört neben
vorbereitet kommt
die sind auf jeden fall notwendig also
die erste prinzipien haben natürlich all
diese eigenschaften die wir immer wenn
die erste prinzipien keine notwendigkeit
oder universal hat hätten dann könnten
sie nicht dann alle diese ja genau das
wollte ich will dass das ist sehr gut
und wofür ich glaube gesagt habe dass
platin oder sollte ich so
unterschiedlich sind weil wir haben
gesehen haben wir gesehen dass platon
der ansicht ist dass das wahrnehmung
wissenschaft gar nicht liefern kann
also wir können nichts anhand der
sinneswahrnehmung oder erfahrung
feststellen was wirklich also dessen
zelt deswegen brauchen wir diese
erinnerungs theorie oder
wiederhergestellt werden
dort ließ es schon der fall so kannst du
sagen nur die welt anschauen oder
erforschen wenn sie es nicht nur
anschauen also oder sehr aktive
anschauen ist was er einst zum beispiel
wie gesagt habe hat er fische zitiert
das ist was er wahrscheinlich im
hinterkopf hat also wenn man wirklich
sehr genau schaut dann begreift man
diese prinzipien oder sieht man wie zum
beispiel tierarten voneinander
unterschieden sind und dann hat man
diese erste prinzipien okay
und also ihr ihre frage für die haus
sowieso den nächsten punkt wollte machen
wollte nämlich dass der geist alles
begreifen kann
genau wie der genau weil der geist wie
sie gesagt haben dass gleiches zu tun
hat wie die welt also die genau wie auge
potenziell grün ist so dass der geist
sozusagen der potenzielle täter nach die
ganze welt oder anders formuliert könnte
man sagen dass das was in dem geist
schon vorhanden ist
in den menschlichen geist von haus aus
ist natürlich kein aktuelles wissen oder
kein wirkliches keine kein wissen der
wirklichkeit nach ist aber wissen der
potenzial i tät nach ist also wir können
das sagen
der geist ist sozusagen gebaut um die
welt zu begreifen ist hat all die
fähigkeiten die man braucht alle formen
auf sich zu nehmen
und es gibt nach art ist laut allofs
gibt es wirklich gar nichts was man
nicht versteht oder verstehen kann
also man kann wirklich die ganze welt
ist verständlich das heißt dass geist
alle natur.de alle eigenschaften der
prozent nach schon besitzt ok und jetzt
sehen wir dass er sehr optimistisches
jetzt ein psychologisch sehr
optimistisch ist er geht davon aus
natürlich können menschen wissen
erwerben was muss der fall sein damit
wir das machen können
wir müssen potenzielle identisch mit der
welt sein
das ist die antwort und da er natürlich
sicher ist dass man wissen er werden
kann können eher darauf schließen dass
der geist so erst es gibt ein ein
weiterer einen weiteren schluss was er
daraus ziehen kann was etwas
überraschender ist nämlich dass der
geist kein organ hat kein körperliches
organ hat wie kann er das daraus
beweisen
na ja denken wir noch mal an unser auge
wir haben gesehen dass auge ist der
prozent sie alltag nach grün oder das
sagt schon das heißt dass uns die
flüssigkeit im auge durchsichtig ist
also wie wasser an scheinen also nochmal
werde dieses zwei nicht besprechen ob
die flüssigkeit der grünen wird grün
grün wird aber irgendwie geht er schon
davon aus wenn die flüssigkeit in dem
auge schon grün wäre also wenn man
mensch menschen haugen abschneiden würde
und sein alles ist gründen
dann könnten wir nicht richtig sehen
wieso also entweder weil wir permanent
grün sein würden war das auge isst schon
grün der wirklichkeit nach oder
vielleicht würden wir das nicht merken
so sagen dass es diese werden wie ein
hintergrund
und alles wäre grün gefärbt wie wenn man
grüne brille an hals oder vielleicht
nicht arbeiten könnten was man wird
sicherlich nicht machen könnte wäre
zuerst nicht grün zu sehen dann grün
sehen und dann wieder nicht grün sehen
und dann wieder grün sein weil man ist
schon grün im auge aber das sehvermögen
hat natürlich einmal ein organ hat
nämlich das auge aber das ist kein
problem weil das die einzige
eigenschaften dem das auge in neutral
gegenüber sein muss sind farben also
dass die flüssigkeit in den augen muss
neutral sein aber nur fahrten gegenüber
weil farben sind das was wir sehen
das auge isst nichts zum beispiel darf
zb flüssigkeit haben und feucht sein
weil man flüssigkeit nicht direkt sieht
ja man kann feuchtigkeit oder
flüssigkeit an tasten und fühlen spüren
mit den fingern weil die finger weder
feucht noch hart noch trocken sind die
sind genau in der mitte wie wir gesehen
haben
also das heißt dass im allgemeinen wir
sagen wenn wir eine kognitive fähigkeit
hat die irgendwas begreifen kann darf
das organen dieser fähigkeit keine
eigenschaften schon der wirklichkeit
nach besitzen
verstehen sie was ich meine also wenn
wenn das organische und giggs ist kann
ich mit diesem organ ich zeit nicht
begreifen
aber ich habe gerade gesagt geist kann
alles begreifen feuchtigkeit trockenheit
härte wärme frosch mensch welt alles und
das heißt wenn geist schon irgendeine
eigenschaft der wirklichkeit nach
besitzen würde würde würde geist diese
eigenschaft nichts denken können
jedes organ würde natürlich irgend
welche eigenschaften haben mindestens
große oder sowas
oder nehmen wir an das wäre das gehirn
das gehirn ist grauenvoll
wenn mein geist wirklich mein gehirn
werde könnte ich nie feucht oder grau
haid begreifen weil mein gehirn und
deswegen mein geist bärisch und grauens
das ist ein argument warum die der geist
kein keine kein organ also keine
aktuelle oder wirkliche eigenschaften
das ist nicht sehr überzeugend glaube
ich und ein grund ist ist genau das was
wir mit dem auge gesehen haben
man vermutet dass wenn das auge sieht
das müsste nicht heißen dass das auge
grün wehrt ja und es ist irgendwie
plausibel so sagen das auch ein grünes
auge die farbe von grün aufnehmen könnte
nachdem das noch nicht anwesend werde
aber geistig zu sagen und ähnlicher
weise scheint es dass die art und weise
wie mein geist feuchtigkeit als objekt
wahrnimmt oder begreift ist nicht die
art und weise wie mein gehirn
feuchtigkeit besetzt
also es gibt es gibt einen unterschied
zwischen eine eigenschaft zu ist da
installieren und als intention als
objekt zu begreifen um das etwas
technisch auszudrücken
also dass dieses argument finde ich
nicht so toll es gibt aber später
vielleicht bessere argumente mit
ästhetischen christen für die und
körperlichkeit des geistes zum beispiel
arizona ein muslimischer philosoph
dachte wenn es wirklich so ist dass wir
mit dem geist immer universelle
eigenschaften und prämisse begreifen
dann
kann der geist nicht in einem organ sein
weil mit erde ist immer das was
universelle eigenschaften als einzel
sachen instanziert also wir sind alle
menschen und jeder von uns ist ein
einzeldenkmal menschheit in einem körper
oder in materie daran anwesen ist also
wenn geist materie befassen würde oder
ein körper wäre könnte geist nur
einzelne dinge begreifen aber genau das
was der geist machen sollte er ist
universell eigenschaften und formen zu
begreifen
deswegen hat der geist keine organe also
man kann aus der esoterische zutaten
aristotelischen zutaten argumente für
die und körperlichkeit des geistes
basteln zusammen
aber hin oder her was sehr klar es ist
ist dass der geist kein organ hat und
keine körperlichen fähigkeit hat es ist
nicht wie sehvermögen oder tasten oder
sogar vorstellungen geist ist und
körperlich und deswegen war es sehr oft
der fall
das späte der interpreten im mittelalter
spätantike als sie dieses problem
besprochen haben was mit der serie
passiert nachdem der sterben
sie haben sehr oft gesagt der dies sagt
genau dasselbe wie platon nämlich dass
die seele vom körper getrennt überleben
kann und wird einfach da nur ein geist
sein
also wir sind alle reine philosophen
nachdem wir sterben sind nur mit dem
geist aktiv
apropos aktiver geist gibt es dann das
letzte was nicht besprechen gibt es eine
passage in diesem text über die zelle
die super schwer zu verstehen ist mein
ärgerliches senden sehr leid zu
verstehen
aber diese passage ist eigentlich nicht
verständlich was wirklich schade ist
weil das thema offensichtlich sehr
wichtig ist was er sagt ist irgendwie
man sieht dass irgendwas wichtiges
gesagt wird aber was genau dass es ist
sehr unsicher
es handle sich hier von kapitel 5 vom
buch 3 also er hat das alles erklärt
geist ist potenzial etat reformen zu
begreifen und dann sagt ja ja wo auch
immer wir in der natur potenzial i tät
finden finden wir auch wirklichkeit also
muss ist ein geist geben
der immer wirklich ist und das wird wie
licht sein
wieso erinnern wir uns arbeiten daran
nichts
obwohl dieser geist ewig ist ist eine
interessante frage
das war das beste dass dieses kapitel
und jetzt denken sie wahrscheinlich alle
hier und das ist genau die richtige
reaktion
also es ist sehr unfair ist super knapp
das sind vielleicht sehen sein auf
griechisch oder von den zahlen und was
erst einmal ist wirklich unklar
und es gab es viele theorien in der sohn
habe der spätantike darüber was er sagen
wollte aber eine plausible erklärung
dafür ist dass er hier an gott denkt was
schwierig es ist wenn der wettergott
beschritt ist es schwer zu verstehen
warum er warum er sich fragt warum wir
uns nicht warum wir an diesem tag nicht
mehr erinnern können
weil
also das impliziert mehr dass das dass
das eine fähigkeit unserer seele ist
oder so was aber eine möglichkeit
mindestens ist dass er hier von einem
permanent aktiven internet spricht und
das würde ich sehr gut so ist eine
beschreibung von gott passen also kurz
jetzt letzten zehn minuten was sagt
alles zu gott
es gibt zwei texte wo ihr dieses thema
bespricht nämlich physik buch 89
metaphysik buch soll und die die zwei
gottes die zwei theorien die wir über
gott in diesen zwei texten finden sind
nicht unbedingt leichter in verbindung
zu bringen
aber dieses problem werde ich nichts so
bestrafen weil es so kompliziert wird
ich werde nur die grobe richtung seiner
gottes liebe beschreiben
ok zuerst jetzt werden wir unseren
frosch verlieren haben jetzt alle genug
denn den frosch okay lass ich las den
crash aber das auge muss sich vision
wie schaut das universum haus nahe des
ortes wie sie wahrscheinlich alle wissen
ist das universum eine sphäre in der
mitte gibt es das erde
das ist kein planet bedeckt ist bewegt
sich nicht ist der mittelpunkt des
ganzen universums hier ganz außen um in
dieser größeres wäre übrigens das
besteht aus vorher luft erde wasser
außerhalb der erde gibt es weitere
sphären die durchsichtig sind und aus
einem fünften element was sich nun in
kreisförmige bewegungen bewegen kann
während die vier elemente richtlinie in
richtlinien sich bewegen also vorher
geht drauf herunter ganz am rand des
universums gibt es die sogenannte
fixsterne
aber wenn sie den himmel beobachten was
die antiken die antike leute ist ja oft
gemacht haben werden sie sehen dass
manche sichtbare sterne sich gegen
diesen hintergrund der fixsterne bewegen
oder wandern da haben wir daher das wird
planet heißt wandern oder wandern der
stern
und um das zu erklären sagt hat es dort
hieß es dass es weiteres fern
innerhalb dieser großes großen sphäre
das sind immer und auf diesen sind die
planeten zum und sonne und mond sind
übrigens planeten
diese theorie also wir haben hier
draußen all diese fixsterne und sie
drehen sich einmal pro tag der erde
das kann man sogar während der nacht
beobachten und natürlich weiß ja dass
das alles wäre das der herr ball einmal
ist und er denkt dass die fed stelle
gehen ganz so krumm einmal pro tag die
planeten werden mit das mitgetragen von
dem großen großen es werde also werden
sozusagen mitgezogen mit den fixsternen
haben aber dann kleine veränderungen
oder kleine kleine bewegungen wodurch
sie dann von den feststellungen
abweichen und deswegen sieht man dass
zum beispiel jupiter ein bisschen nach
links sieht den fixsternen relativ und
durch den dort das ganze jahr ist das
sehr auffällig es gibt vielleicht mehr
denn pro planet weil die bewegungen der
planeten sind nicht kompliziert sind
aber die grundlegende idee ist dass
jedes fähre eine einfache kreis
kreisförmige bewegung hat und wenn man
alles zusammennimmt das ist alles super
kompliziert aber am ende soll das den
die beobachtungen dann erklären die wir
mit den positionen der stände machen
können
und also alles ewig ein grün zu denken
dass das universum hebel ist übrigens
dass diese mit herde voraus die spar
himmel stemmen
die ist ein engel bestehen es sind
unzerstörbar
man hat auch argumente weil warum sie
uns zerstörbar sind jetzt große frage
woher kommt diese bewegung wie ich meine
das war immer so dies wären haben eine
ewige konstante bewegung kreisförmig
aber wir sehen keine erklärung dafür
und nochmal wir wollen immer um alles zu
verstehen wollen wir einmal die ursache
finden was ist die ursache für diese
bewegung antwort jedes wäre hat einen
beweger der dies werde in bewegung setzt
ohne selbst bewegt zu werden und das
ganze system hat einen saison nur
beweger der bewegung die schnellste
bewegung darf der schwede der fixsterne
und das ist gott
es ist ein bisschen wie gott und engel
das ist genau wie andere die wie zb im
mittelalter das würde genauso ausgelegt
die bewegung für die inneren werte sind
engel und der bewegung für die äußeres
werde
ist gott der sie selbst sagt das ist
wahrscheinlich was woher wird diese
traditionelle ideen über die götter
haben das ist so eine fuchs fassung
von meine wissenschaftliche erklärung
für die himmels bewegung was er übrigens
sehr interessante erst auf jeden fall
dass wir ihn sehr wichtig ist ist aber
dass die diese götter und vor allem der
gott und hoher bewege die selbst sind
nicht in bewegung
dies sind sozusagen nur da nicht
körperlich weil geister keine körper
besitzen und sie setzen irgendwie die
bewegung des fern in gang
wieso können diese bewegung nicht selbst
in bewegung sein
das ist ein bisschen wie das was wir in
der technologie gesehen haben
es gibt einen thron des regresses wenn
jede bewegung durch eine weitere
bewegung verbessert wird dann kommen wir
in eine kette eine erklärung ist kette
zu sagen wo für bewegung nummer 13
müssen wir bewegung nummer 14
dann dann erwähnen muss so weiter und so
fort dann haben wir unendlich viele
bewegungen was mit unseren beobachtungen
nicht übereinstimmt also was wir
brauchen ist das am ende so sein dass
wir einen beweger haben der keine
bewegung erleidet und so gar nicht wie
sich nicht bewegen kranken und das ist
gott und die an der bewegung
was macht gott die ganze zeit sehr
auffällig erschafft die welt gar nichts
die welt ist nichts geschaffen die welt
ist ewig es gibt keine erklärung für die
existenz der ex-bayer dass dort ließ die
frage ist ihm gar nicht eingefallen
scheint die welt ist da und kein wunder
also wenn sogar zum beispiel frösche
derart nach ewig sind da natürlich ist
die welt ewig und wenn die hält welt
ewiges das ist nur eine tatsache die
welt ist einfach notwendig da
aber dann könnte man denkt okay wieso
braucht ja gott wenn er die welt aus um
beschaffen versteht nicht um die
existenz der welt so erkennt sondern die
bewegung der welt zu erklären waren
diese ewige kreisförmige bewegungen
haben wie sie sich vorstellen können war
das ein riesenproblem für spätere banker
also im mittelalter und sogar in der
spätantike zu erklären dass sie
eigentlich zu verteidigen dass sie die
ganze zeit als dort ließ auslegen und
denken flüsse wie es mit alles rot ist
identisch zu sein und euro übrig eines
buchs er dachte dass es keinen schöpfer
gibt ähnlich und deswegen ist eine eine
haupt streit der mit leute ist ob die
welt tätig ist oder nicht und theologen
sagen typischerweise ihr philosophen ihr
seid eigentlich ketzer weil er hält die
in dem hier alles wollte er sagt dass
die welt ewiges und michael vieles offen
vor allem in der islamischen welt teilte
diese meinung als beispielhaft seien
allerdings schon heute erwähnt habe er
dachte dass die welt tätig ist
theologen und philosophen in latein
mittel halte fast immer zugegeben dass
die welt nicht ewig ist also dass die
welt geschafft in der zeit geschaffen
würde
aber manchmal sagte sie so etwas wie
naja wenn man nur naturphilosophie macht
und physik macht würde man beweisen dass
die welt ewig existiert nur durch
offenbarung wissen wir dass das doch
nicht der fall ist weil es gibt auch
über natürliche ursachen wie gott und
das ist nicht sehr glücklich
natürlich war dann hat man eine spannung
zwischen glaube und wissenschaft war es
zum beispiel einen thomas von aquin
vermeiden wollte so thomas
beispielsweise er wollte er hatte
argumentiert dass man keine
philosophische argumente für keine gute
argumente für oder gegen die ewigkeit
der wand bringen kann
für das vieh lässt offen ob die welt
ewig ist oder nicht und wir wissen die
antwort nur auf die offenbarung
es gibt keine spannung zwischen
offenbarung und wissenschafts oder
flüssen film also sein haupt streit für
die späte der historische tradition
nächste woche wird um hätte gehen und
übernächste woche wird gott wieder
auftauchen aber nur kurz